Don't try this at home, kids!
My first impression of Quebec City is that everyone is so warm and friendly.
It's really welcoming, you know, from the United States, from New York City,...
...people can be a bit cold at times, and here, everyone is so warm and friendly.
Nina Pizza might be my favorite place so far,...
...and the pizza was great; it was amazing.
We went to the Dufferin Terrace toboggan slide and that was amazing.
I felt like a little kid again.
I never experienced going through any sort of large structure only made of ice.
The museum was beautiful,...
...and to hear about the history of art in Quebec especially in the 50s and 60s...
...and some of that art that was being created with a rebellious spirit.
I love snow and architecture and see the how the snow affects the city.
It was just gorgeous.
It was kind of sunny this morning and then boom!
It's crazy; I don't feel like I'm five hours from New York.
I really feel like I'm in Europe or something.
Staying in Quebec City was such a delight and such a pleasant surprise,...
...and I can't recommend it enough.
I can't wait to come back and do it again.